male theft many in the Northwest Valley
are on high alert after their mailboxes
were vandalized and their mail was taken
Madison Kimbrough spoke with some who
are concerned she joins us live in
Centennial hills with more Madison
yeah here in the Sierra Hills Community
of Centennial Hills neighbor Mike May
shares with me video that he's obtained
of people vandalizing his neighborhood
mailbox as it's becoming a common thing
across the Northwest Valley according to
those in the area as Mike and his
neighbors share next door threads of
several different neighborhoods being
targeted many filing police reports also
contacting the postal service for help
many neighbors stating they believe they
are being targeted because it is
election season thinking that these
thieves are going after mail-in ballots
now may who has video of the culprits
from his security camera says he
initially thought this was an isolated
case of mail theft but soon realized the
ongoing trend
it's more about data and people trying
to steal people's information you know
identity theft credit cards checks any
kind of payment information but also at
the same time it could deter people from
voting there could be multiple different
factors to this but you know we won't
know until they're caught
three mailbox units have been tampered
with and several neighbors still without
any idea as to when or if they will get
their mail returned to them and we
reached out to the United States Postal
Service for comment on these thefts
we're still waiting to hear back
reporting in Centennial hills Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now